hey what's up ladies and gentlemen
today's video is going to be a part two
of the teaser breakdown because there is
something I wanted to mention in my
previous video but I thought everyone
would say I'm batshit crazy
but after seeing some comments from you
it appears that a good bit of you
actually feel the same way that I
originally did so let's talk about the
blue eye that appeared at the end of the
teaser trailer and what I actually think
it could be now the safe answer would be
that it's simply the knight Kings eye
but after looking further into it I
actually think it's the eye of a dragon
and there are a few reasons why I think
this to be true so let's go over those
reasons then you can tell me whether or
not I'm ready
the first reason has to do with the
number of dragons we see in this teaser
which this was something that I pointed
out yesterday in my first teaser
breakdown video when the teaser begins
we can see three dragon heads as
Daenerys delivers her first quote but by
the end of this teaser when all the
sigils start to crack and break apart
there is only two dragon heads which
leads me to believe that one of the
dragons will die by the end of season 7
now obviously season 7 is going to start
off with three dragons but since this
teaser ends with only showing us two
dragons I feel like they did that for a
reason and that's because one of them is
going to die but that doesn't
necessarily mean that dragon is going to
be turned into one of the Night Kings
zombie dragons so this leads me to the
second reason I think this could be a
dragon's blue eye at the end of this
teaser according to the front leaked Jon
Snow will go north of the wall to
capture a white while doing this Jon
Snow and several other characters he is
with will get ambushed by the night king
and hundreds if not thousands of whites
and this is when Daenerys is supposed to
show up with their dragons and help
rescue them but again according to the
plot week the night King is able to kill
one of her dragons and turn it into a
zombie dragon mount for himself but this
does not mean this will happen just
because it says that but let's look at
the evidence surrounding this scene the
first thing I want to say is this plot
league came out at the end of October
but we didn't start seeing photos that
related to this scene until several
months later and one of the first photos
that was leaked after the plot leaked
was this one which appears to be a
frozen lake with an island in the center
or more than likely for John snow to
stand on and be surrounded by wings so
that matches up perfectly with the
setting the leek laid out it also said
John snow would go north of the wall to
capture white wood Poorman the hound
Joro Gendry Thoros barrack and benjin
would even show up later to rescue John
and whenever Game of Thrones filmed
scenes that are taking place north of
the wall
they always film those themes in Iceland
because of its icy and treacherous
looking landscapes well guess who
started shelling up in Iceland months
after the leak stated this would happen
every single one of these characters
arrived in Iceland the film even uncle
Benjen showed up with characters he
would otherwise have no business being
with and most recently more photos came
out and it was a photo of a single wait
now does this mean this is the way Jon
Snow allegedly captures no not
necessarily this could just be a
close-up of one way but to me I think
this is the white that they go and
capture but that's just my opinion
and reports had also came out that said
they had casted over 300 people to use
as whites for this ambush scene so since
everything from that episode has
appeared to come true then that leads me
to believe that dragon will die in that
episode as well if these photos were
leaked first then that would make
perfect sense while someone would write
it scene saying all this happened but
since the scene was leaked first then
the photos came out later I have to
believe this is what we're going to see
but this isn't even the most important
part of the leak that leads me to
believe this is a dragon's blue eye on
this teaser in the leaked it says the
very last scene we get is the dragon's
eye opening up and turning blue then the
scene will fade to black
which is the exact same way they ended
this teaser which feels like this could
be the very last scene we get in season
7 and I think that would be a powerful
way to end season 7 in my opinion if the
wall falls down and one of the dragons
is turned into a white dragon do you
know how terrifying that would be to
live in that world and have that happen
it would almost feel like there is
nothing you could do but let's move on
from a plot leaked and let's just
examine this eye for a little bit after
I saw this eye and thought it could be
the dragon's eye
first I had to go look at photo
is a benign king himself and see if it
resembled his eye in any way and after
looking at several photos of the 19 this
eye doesn't even appear to be the same
shade of blue as the mite king and not
only is it not the same shade of blue
but look at the shape of the eye from
this teaser it's almost like a football
kind of like a reptiles eye which is
basically what a dragon is just a big
flying lizard that also breeds fire of
course so I want to show you a few
different photos of the main King and
put the photos of this eye from the
teaser side-by-side and tell me if you
think it looks anything like the night
King died because I don't think it's the
same shape or color then look at the
shape of a dragon's eye it's shaped just
like a football which is exactly like
the blue eye they show at the end of
this teaser and this is the only photo I
saw the night King in which his eyes had
the same shape from the eye and the
teaser but even in this one
his eyes are piercing electric blue
which is nothing like the color of the
eye from the teaser the shape is the
same here but that's only because the
way he was looking at brand when he was
about to grab him and even when the main
teen changes the eye color of the baby
they are still piercing blue eyes so my
guess would be since the dragon's eyes
are so dark they are not going to change
to that piercing blue color that humans
lives but maybe that's just a stretch at
first glance I assumed it was the mite
Kings eye but I'm not so sure about that
I think it could be the eye of one of
the Dragons considering its shape and
color plus the plot league did say a
dragon would turn during season 7 and
the league also said the very last scene
we would get would be the dragon opening
its blue eye after being turned since
the last image in this teaser was the
blue eye maybe this is the same image we
will see in that last scene with the
dragon being turned into a white but
comment below and tell me what you think
about this am I crazy or is it possible
let me know your thoughts either way
thanks for watching I appreciate your
time I appreciate your support thanks
for stopping by I will see you guys on
the next one bye
you